going back to this three-dimensional
character you don't have to name who the
characters were but in terms of talking
about three dimension is that the high
the mid and then the absolute low right
can you can you get your samples of just
just generic versions of what you might
show well let me tell you this let's
look at your life oh well let's look it
let's look at my life because I'm I'm
terribly narcissistic in my life I have
maybe one day a month where I lose my
temper in any way that anyone would
notice that I was upset and even then I
get what I jokingly call parenthetically
upset if someone's like are you mad
because I get almost held at you're mad
most of the time I'm pretty mellow and
then maybe once a month I'll get really
emotional about something and get down
those three things are all different
parts of my character if I condensed
those moments down into a show where
you're seeing that happen to me over the
course of 30 minutes or an hour you
start to feel that I have a range of
emotions that can be displayed that I am
not just the guy who is the bad boss or
the guy who is the wacky fun person to
be around you're getting an idea that i
have a very rich personal life if you
see me reacting in many different ways
to things in a span of a half an hour or
an hour you start to get the idea that i
have a richness to my character that i
have an emotional range if you only see
me on a show as I'm the oppressive boss
you know I'm the ditzy underlaying I'm
the guy who bumbles around it never gets
anything right you might as well be
watching you know traditional comedies
where people tend to be pigeonholed and
those archetypes are are more prevalent
I won't say that reality shows don't
have types I won't say that we don't say
well you know we're looking for the rock
star and the virgin and
this and the VAT that they often cast
that way to get those things but when
you show those characters you've got to
let them have that that range of emotion
or people don't believe that they're
real you can't invest in someone who is
in one state all the time so speaking of
which what are the archetypes that are
on most reality shows character well
I'll tell you the character archetypes
and reality shows very they're very it's
very broad there are certain things like
when you watch the real world is the
best way to sort of understand you know
how they cast if you look at those shows
it's the cowboy the rich kid like
everybody is just this is exactly who I
am I'm the crazy drunk I'm the person
who has you know deep-rooted issues I'm
the social activist and they'll try to
build things around those people so that
they can showcase the things that
they're passionate about because that's
where their energy comes through but as
far as archetypes go there's there are
zillions of them in reality television
you cast for them with an eye towards
conflict they don't tend to cast people
to get along the cat's people so that
there will be some sort of discussion or
disagreement because that's where
dramatic action happens fantastic
example of that the surreal life season
two they had ron jeremy who is an adult
film star and they had tammy faye baker
who was of course is the the famous
televangelist and they put them in a
house together because they were sure
that they would butt heads about
something and then developing a
friendship over the course of that
season was one of the most amazing
things I've ever seen in a reality show
it was really fun to watch them get to
know each other and for him to know when
not to push her and for her to realize
that she needed to be a little bit more
a little bit accepting of him and it all
worked out in the end but that's why I
say you know people have people have to
change over the course of a season and
develop the same way that they do in
scripted content but it all has to go
somewhere
just the state of being is not enough so
then it's not so much that someone's
cast as the villain it's in terms of
what is their hot button what is their
Achilles heel that they know somebody
pokes them with it they're gonna explode
and it's going to create conflict sure
well when you're applying to be on a
reality show usually you'll get that
your little do little form and it'll say
the thing that most embarrassed me when
I was younger was this my biggest fear
is blah I can almost guarantee you that
if you fill out my biggest fear is
spiders somewhere in that season a
tarantula is going to show up or there's
going to be yes you might have an
encounter with a spider or if you say
the thing that embarrassed me most was
you know I I was a lousy surf border in
the surf town or whatever maybe there's
going to be a challenge that year where
you have to be on a surfboard they try
to find out those things about you so
they know what they can do to bring your
personality out it's working towards
bringing the person's personality it's
not done maliciously it's done so that
we can see who you are and what makes
you tick in a more defined way
you